if Impractical Jokers isn't your thing
and practical jokers the movie isn't
going to change your mind if you dig the
show's ridiculous sense of humor though
you'll like the movie to know it's not
perfect but then again what is
unsurprisingly the best thing about
Impractical Jokers the movie is also the
best thing about Impractical Jokers the
television show it has a setup that
works the movies heart is the
hidden-camera pranks just like the
series typically these all use the same
format members of the cast are put into
fairly mundane situations for example
they need to flag down help when their
car breaks down on the highway while
their comrades watch from afar the Joker
or Jokers and the hot seats are wearing
earpieces and have to do whatever the
others tell them if you've seen the show
you know exactly what to expect
Joe just open-mouth sneeze on the wall
if a joker refuses to follow directions
or can't accomplish his goal he gets a
thumbs down whoever has the most thumbs
down at the end loses the movie works
the same way it's just longer south cue
Joe and Murr are all extremely talented
improvisers sand easily come up with new
ways to torture their friends and spin
their team members outrageous demands
into comedy gold
so what have you seen it before like
they say if it's not broken don't fix it
that's good that's solid doesn't for
sure escape at this point there are over
200 episodes of the show plus more than
30 TV specials that's a lot of
Impractical Jokers
and while the movie doesn't reference at
all it does the best that can one gag
place on Sal's well-established fear of
cats
another recalls a bit from all the way
back in season two when Q had to teach
his parents sex ed have you seen every
episode of Impractical Jokers these
callbacks should delight you oh god that
looks like it was
oh it's Maui on the other hand if you're
new to the show your mileage will
probably vary the movie catches newbies
up on what they need to know but a few
punchlines don't really land unless
you've been following the game full-time
Impractical Jokers is a funny show but
it's a modest one a lot of the action
takes place in shopping malls in city
parks the challenges are simple and on
average the punishments are pretty
low-key not so in the movie while the
film still relies on the charm and
talent of its cast for its humor the
bigger budget and extra scope gives the
group room to go a little bigger it's
hard to imagine Jaden Smith stopping by
to help with one of the pranks in the
show the guys could have easily made a
bigger more extravagant episode of the
TV series and called in a movie instead
they decided to give the film an actual
story it's not clear why the film opens
when the Joker's were still in high
school and chronicles their mishaps at a
Paula Abdul concert gone wrong in the
present day the quartet get the
opportunity to redeem themselves when
Abdul recognizes them at a Red Lobster
and invites them to a party she's
throwing in Miami there's just one
problem
she sent three tickets and so is the
Joker's travel from Long Island Florida
they compete in a series of prank
battles to see who gets left out
unfortunately the pre-scripted plot
scenes drag everything to a halt
Joe cue Sal and Murr are funny guys but
they're not great actors and none of the
jokes really hit there's a reason
they're sketch comedy spin-off didn't
even finish at six episode run after all
and practical jokers doesn't need to
explain why these guys are playing
pranks it's just what they do even worse
the story doesn't really lead to
anything either it's mostly there to
fill time and it feels completely
unnecessary what advice would you give
filmmakers starting out in order to help
them to avoid the pitfalls that you
clearly fell into it
Impractical Jokers is uncomfortable but
it's never cool well jackass is about
inflicting pain and Borak goes out of
its way to make its targets look like
idiots and practical jokers only real
victims are the Joker's themselves
regular civilians might suffer minor
inconveniences but the final joke is
always on Joe Sal Murr and Q in the
movie The Joker's often decide it's
better to lose a challenge than put
unsuspecting
civilians in awkward situations instead
of robbing Impractical Jokers of its
edge the compassionate approach actually
makes the movie funnier Impractical
Jokers isn't just a prank show it's a
competition well the ultimate goal might
be to make the audience laugh each
member of the cast spends every episode
doing his best to win the challenge at
hand
after all if you fail you get turned
into a human pinata forced to face down
a crowd of angry bingo players or worse
did I tell you - you're gonna take a
deep breath those punishments were all
real the one in the movie isn't missing
out on a fake party isn't exactly the
same as being strapped to a table while
tarantulas walk all over you and the
film suffers for it the consequences
aren't real so there's no reason to care
the movie has punishments of course and
they're some of the best parts of the
film but they don't work the same way
they do on the show on TV the
punishments are consequences for failure
in the movie they're random asides that
pop up as the Joker's travel across the
country and it doesn't make them any
less funny but it does make the movie
even less exciting than an episode of
television Joe Q Sal and Murr literally
grew up together and their close bond
comes through on-screen they know
exactly how to push each other's buttons
a skill that comes in pretty handy when
you're trying to put your buddy through
hell but they have an easy camaraderie
that lends itself well to comedy in a
way that's what makes Impractical Jokers
pre-scripted scene so jarring one of the
things that makes Impractical Jokers
special is that the Joker's are clearly
real people
the film's story segments however
transform all of them into cartoon
characters that really doesn't work the
movie is at its best when their
real-life bond is on full display
Impractical Jokers is a short movie it
clocks in at just over an hour and a
half and most of it breezes right by
near the end of the film however things
begin to drag you're waiting for one big
final lap that never comes you know to
the no no no I'm so sorry
again it's not that big of a deal the
rest of the movie is fun and likeable
and you'll leave the theater having had
a good time still something as good as
Impractical Jokers the movie deserves a
real climax or at least a little
broccoli time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]